the first game on saturday is the first
home playoff game for the buffalo bills
since december of 1996.
they will welcome 6700 fans into
bills stadium to watch their old afc
east rivals the cults come to town let's
hear from the two quarterbacks in this
game josh
allen and phillip rivers from earlier in
the week
i think the main lesson was not to press
understand the situation that we were in
um obviously if i can go back and change
things i would
um but i'm glad that they went down the
way that they went down
i was able to learn a lot from that and
hopefully uh carry that
you know playoff experience into uh into
saturday's game i don't carry that with
me uh day to day that you know man
played 16 years never
never been you know part of a champion i
i don't i really don't
um we strive for it strive for it every
year and striving for it like crazy this
year but
it's not something i feel heavy uh
or something something i'm carrying
around with me shooting it's a new
new uh new new beginning every day and
excited for each challenging opportunity
josh allen was talking about his
struggles in the playoff game last year
he was great early but
just right on that edge of out of
control the weird flip over his head
as the game was falling apart maybe just
a manifestation of the frustration he
was feeling because he didn't have the
weapons
that that would match his skills well
now his skills have improved the weapons
have improved
and i think that's going to be a real
challenge peter
for josh allen and i think he's up to it
but he
he needs to make us forget all about the
guy that we saw
in those bad moments against the texans
last year when they blew the 16 point
lead and lost in overtime
he needs to make us absolutely never
think about that
and he shouldn't think about it too much
he just needs to go out and play the way
he's been playing
yeah i you know to me mike that's a
little bit in the rear view mirror
because we've seen
such a different quarterback this year
and
you know he's become a quarterback who
is extremely confident both
in and out of the pocket my biggest
question about this game for buffalo
honestly
is if cole beasley plays i mean cole
beasley is the slot receiver on my all
pro team this year
this year the associated press asked
voters
uh to vote for three wide receivers they
didn't put any
limit they didn't put any restrictions
on how you vote for them
and look i mean i probably would have
voted uh
as my third receiver for somebody like
tyreek hill
but i like to put my votes
for uh you know for players as if
i was going to play a game and so i want
a slot receiver on my team and cole
beasley
led all nfl slot receivers in yardage
this year and he was the most effective
efficient
receiver in that ping pong ball type
area
of the slot this year if he's not there
he's become a real security blanket
you know for josh allen if he's not
there if he's limited or restricted in
any way
i think that's a big boost for
indianapolis
he did practice yesterday which is good
news for the buffalo bills he was week
to week with that knee injury he
suffered in week 16.
stefan diggs questionable as well he
missed practice wednesday was back
thursday he's got no bleak injury but
obviously that's a huge issue
for josh allen and i agree with you it's
like he's a different guy than he was a
year ago
but this is his first time back to
single elimination football
since a year ago and part of the
challenge just like with lamar jackson
you got to find a way to forget about
what happened last year learn the
lessons
that you can from last year incorporate
them into your game
but ultimately forget about last year
and focus on forging a new legacy and
you know for philip rivers he falls into
that category of guys
for whom it could be it we talked
earlier about what could happen with the
colts especially if they lose and
will they want him back the networks are
starting to eyeball phillip rivers and i
think he would be awesome in the booth
and he could make plenty of money in the
booth and not be in harm's way and he
could do that for 25 years if he wants
to
so a lot of questions about where these
two quarterbacks are
moving in their career trajectories but
josh allen's moving into the top three
frankly right now
for the cults peter do you have in mind
any sort of
a strategy a recipe a formula
for pulling off what would be i think
for most people a pretty significant
upset although i think these two teams
may be closer than the point spread
would suggest
yeah 30 years ago mike in the what was
the absolute total unequivocal
nightmare scenario game in the great
buffalo bills run
everybody will remember the scott
norwood uh wide right kick by
eight inches or whatever it was that
cost them that game
but what i really remember about that
game
is the fact that the new york giants
went into it
saying we are going to limit the number
of
possessions that uh that our opponent
is going to get in this super bowl you
know remember comments got five
field goals to uh beat the 49ers
capitalized on a late fumble uh that
might have been the best 49ers team of
all time and
the giants beat him that year and in
what the 49ers still
be moan as a lost opportunity
um and and obviously the the bills beat
oakland 51 to
nothing or whatever it was and parcells
whole philosophy in that game was
you got to shorten the game you got to
play clock ball and if i were the
indianapolis colts i were frank reich
this week i would be telling my offense
i'd be telling everybody in that
offensive room
you know just do things to make the
clock keep running
don't go out of bounds just let
make the clock keep running we only want
to give buffalo
eight or nine possessions that is the
crucial thing
and indianapolis's running game has been
so powerful recently that
i think they've got a chance to be able
to do this
and i think if you look up at the end of
the game and you see
colts with 43 rushes
you know i i think obviously this has
got to be a huge day
for jonathan taylor if you look up and
see them with 43 rushes
at the end of the game or you look at
the colts
and or you look at the bill times then
i'm gonna say
you know indianapolis just might have
won this game
the 253 rushing yards from jonathan
taylor last week were amazing
the rookies are supposed to hit a wall
he was used extensively at wisconsin but
he is going strong
and part of that too peter i think comes
down to the awareness of philip rivers
he needs to milk the play clock down to
zero or close to it as often as you
possibly can
when the clock is running and that's
something sims and i talked about
yesterday
and this is one of sims favorite phrases
we used to use it for patrick mahomes
but we can now use it for josh allen
you want him standing on the sideline
drinking gatorade you don't want him in
the game
and then when he gets in the game maybe
he presses a little bit
maybe he's a little frustrated maybe
that frustration manifests itself
because he's not out there on the field
as much as he'd like to be
here we are with fans for the first time
this season and i can't get on the
football field
to do what i'd like to do and you know
the thing about playoff football
if you're the favorite and it doesn't
start well and you can't get it
going you quickly feel
in the pit of your stomach it's all
slipping away that's what makes what the
chiefs did last year so much more
impressive when they were down 24
because it was over it was done see you
later great season chiefs but
but reset to zero and zero and we'll see
you next year to find your way
out of that hole when you know your
season is closing in around you and it's
over and to do it against the titans in
the afc championship to do it against
the 49ers in the super bowl that's truly
remarkable
but uh you know if the cults can just
catch them flat-footed early
and and and do exactly what you've
suggested and and sims and i
went through basically the same formula
yesterday run the ball
milk the clock keep josh allen on the
sidelines if the colts can make it a
game if the colts can hold a lead into
the second half
and if the bills can just start thinking
well you know
what where where can they find that
patrick mahomes
will and determination and ability to
transcend that feeling of
it's all falling apart
you know the other kind of interesting
thing about this game mike that
i don't know how much you guys have
talked about it but frank wright
returning to the scene of his prime
you know you know returning to the place
that
had the greatest comeback and you know
really numerically
a bigger comeback than tom brady did but
you know one of the greatest comebacks
in sports history
and you know i'll never forget being at
that game that night
or that day and waiting waiting waiting
for frank reich at the end of the day
and finally he was the last guy left in
the locker room he had taken his shower
and there was nobody left in the locker
room and i'm waiting
until he's ready to talk to me and
wright turns to
the equipment manager and he says hey if
everybody's gone can you let linda in
i mean i've been waiting you know kept
her waiting for so long
and his wife linda comes into the locker
room at the time
you know with 30 years ago and frank
reich
and they they uh kind of semi-jogged to
each other
like it's one of those commercials and
he lifted her up in the air and i said
oh my god
you know i wish i had a camera to record
this it was it was fantastic
but frank wright was there that day
and frank reich was also on the field in
tampa
the day that the giants you know had
that game against buffalo and i mean
he's got so many fond memories of
everything that happened
in buffalo he loves buffalo and i think
the one thing about this game
it has nothing to do with institutional
knowledge because they're different
teams
but i think frank wright really does
appreciate that there's not going to be
70 000 fans there
making it extraordinarily difficult
for the visiting team to win it's
amazing to think he's such a great
partner of the bill's past
his opportunity to try to stick a knife
into their
into their present uh does add some some
flavor
to this one and that's the one that gets
it started tomorrow
at one o'clock eastern right out of the
gates colts bills
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports